platforma ma problem polegający na tym
że nie ma na pokładzie żadnego polityka wiarygodnego
na wsi wśród rolników
i to nie przypadek
bo jest partią
która popierała
bezwarunkowe otwarcie rynku europejskiego
w tym polskiego
na produkty rolne z ukrainy
jest partią
która popierała piątkę dla zwierząt pisowską
która była piątką przeciw rolnikom
jest partią
która popierała zakazanie hodowli zwierząt futerkowych
a więc to hodowla branża polskiego rolnictwa
to jest partia antyrolnicza
takie skojarzona
popiera wszystkie bzdury z brukseli
takie Jak europejskie zielony ład
w ramach którego ma
być ym ograniczone stosowanie substancji ochronnych
w wyniku czego koszt produkcji rolnej w polsce wyrośnie
przekształcanie obecnych gospodarstw w bagna
no to są absurdy
i platforma to wszystko popiera
i dlatego rolnicy nie chcą głosować na platformę
i w tej chwili tusk robi taki trochę desperacki ruch
bierze gościa
którego retoryka przez ostatnie ileś lat
była nie tylko niekompatybilna z platformą
ale który opluwał zupełnie otwarcie tuska mówiąc
że jest szkodnikiem
że doprowadził polskę do ruiny i tak dalej
no i liczył na to
że w ten sposób wejdą trochę szkodę yy pis-owi na wsi
to się wam nie uda dlatego
że siłą opozycję
która jest wiarygodna wśród rolników jest konfederacja
to my byliśmy na wszystkich manifestacjach z rolnikami
i na granicy i przeciwko piątce dla zwierząt
media może tego nie pokazywały
bo NAS nie faworyzują
natomiast prawda jest taka
że oddolne protesty rolnicze wiedzą na kogo mogą liczyć
wiedzą kto Tam przychodzi
wiedzą kto wspiera
wiedzą kto w sejmie dobrze głosuje pana
zdaniem i
konfederacja też prowadzi rolników do następnego sejmu
prawda zdaniem yy